former atlanta mayor andrew young has
spent his life fighting for racial
equality he was a close friend to the
reverend martin luther king jr and
marched in selma alabama in 1965
to secure voting rights young was later
elected to congress and became the first
african-american u.n ambassador in the
new children's book just like jesse
owens young teams up with his daughter
to write about his own childhood the
book shares a powerful lesson young
learned after nazi sympathizers provoked
racial unrest in his 1930s new orleans
neighborhood young's father took him to
see a newsreel of track star jesse owens
winning four gold medals in the 1936
berlin olympics owen's success showed
young that the best way to fight racism
is to focus on the finish line i like
that ambassador young and his daughter
paula young shelton are joining us now
good morning to you both i just have to
say this is an incredible story about
your childhood you he asked you to help
him in writing this book but what was it
specifically that you wanted people to
hear
well you know
it was the idea of don't get mad get
smart
i love that song and uh
my daddy started me with that at
four
because i was born in 32 this was 36.
and
i had an irish grocery store on one
corner an italian bar on another the
nazi party was on the third corner
and so i i was born into a conglomerate
mess
and i had to get along with everybody
and
my father just said look
you know that god made a one-blood all
the nations of the world
they think
they're special
but that's not your business that's
their problem with god
you mind your business
and you do the best that you can do and
you don't ever let people make you angry
and then i passed that on to paula
but with her it was different because
the little boys were picking on her but
i said that's because they like you
and they think you're cute i said flip
it on them speak to them
be nice to them boys and girls and
before you long she had a
had her own little rat pack
but i remember the first time i came
home to tell you that this boy had
called me the n-word right
and i come home to tell my daddy ready
to get all of his sympathy and he looks
at me and says that poor little boy
and what i realized then is that
racism was not about me what other
people
thought about me was not my problem and
that i really needed to
believe in myself and not let other
people's
racism and
ugliness
reflect who i was because i know who i
am penetrate yourself absolutely the
book ambassador leaves you feeling
optimistic
and it gives hope well is there any
reason why anybody in america
as bad as you think things are yeah
there's a i've been to 152 countries in
this planet
i still look forward to getting back to
atlanta
but do you think these united states of
america with all of their problems we're
still better than anybody else still
hopeful
no not hopeful
it's real
this is not a play game
you know i mean
i can see in 1960
we went to birmingham
and we were in atlanta
because there'd been 60 bombings
of people's homes in birmingham 150
miles away and we didn't know about it
so and so
they had to come over there and get us
and take us back to birmingham and
and and get us to help them to
straighten out birmingham and that's how
we began to straighten out the nation
now with george floyd
everybody saw it within
nine minutes and 41 seconds
all around the world all the way down to
new zealand
and so
we are focusing on the race problems now
but they're not nearly as bad as they
were when i was growing up but they
still do exist
they still do exist oh they'll always
exist because you are a sinner
yeah and you sin and fall short of the
glory of god we're awful you lose your
temper every night and then even
with the woman you love the most
right and she gets angry with you
that's life yeah but don't get mad
get smarter
get smart think about it why is she
upset
i tell you
ambassador young
just thank you so much paula you as well
the book is just like jesse owens it is
on sale now
and we will be
right back